this movie makes me feel less stupid
because I had Legos when I was a kid I
would just stare dumb and be like
alright where's the instructions have a
good imagination except when it comes to
Legos the lego movie
so the lego movie is a movie about a
lego world in this lego world this is
dude he's a lego guy he's a common guy
he's nothing special about him he blends
right in but then he finds a thing and
this thing means another thing and
ultimately this common Lego guy gets
wrapped up in this adventure and then we
see a bunch of Legos and pop-culture
references among a lego world and that's
all cool because we've all had Legos at
least once in our lives and it really is
one of the things that drives this movie
first of all I like the animation in
this movie I think it's all done on
computers but it's meant to look like
stop-motion animation so the stop-motion
animation made it feel like it's
actually Legos like someone has a camera
that zoomed in on these tiny ass Lego
people you're watching their world
operate it's all awesome because they
all build things like they're real Legos
which just now I realize I just said
that Lego people built Legos I'm not
crazy you don't have mean you know it's
cool seeing Lego things get built
everything in this movie is done with
Legos even explosion happen something
blows up the explosion the fire the
smoke all done with Legos makes you step
back you're like I guess you really can
create everything with Legos I've seen
some crazy Lego things that should have
been my first indication on that fact
when you see an entire movie built
around Legos that's just really
impressive even if it was done on a
computer and among having all these
different worlds it allows them a lot of
opportunities to make pop-culture
references but it makes the movie feel a
little broken up also this movies
written by a couple different people and
it shows you feel like they wanted to
showcase a lot of different Lego worlds
but in that movie feels like you could
have had one Lego world completely
removed from this movie you'd be like
okay thank you for reconciling that the
movie is now not too long which I get
for a lego movie the possibilities are
endless you want to show it all you got
to be careful not to make the movie too
long because of it in that the setup in
this movie I was like I don't know where
this movie's going really some of the
jokes at the beginning didn't really
land with me it took me a few minutes to
get into the movie and after that the
movie starts making me chuckle and
that's good then something happened in
the movie that me
oh that is awesome that's awesome we're
talking really awesome those of you who
know me when you watch the movie you're
gonna be like that's the moment Jeremy
was talking about and you will be right
so as enjoyable as all this stuff is in
the movie I was watching I was like
enjoyable movie then the last 15 20
minutes of the movie happens and I was
like all right now it's a great movie
seriously the last 15 minutes of this
movie it's like they got the guy who
wrote Toy Story 3 and they were like can
you please write this he was like not a
problem friends yeah I don't even have
to be credited with it now we have the
end of this movie that stuff really hits
you where you live it just hit your
heartstrings you're like okay it's one
of these we're not in January anymore
new thank you any other movie month of
the year for happening finally so in the
end the lego movie was enjoyable it was
a little long-winded in times and not
all of the jokes land you watch it
you're like all right maybe it's made
for kids and they're really relatable
jokes for us older kids or man-children
lands and the end happens and you walk
out of move and you're like I can't say
it wasn't great and the animation come
on seeing Legos do their thing is always
cool I was gonna say this movie's a good
time no alcohol required but it just
it's like a wine it starts getting
better as it ages and by ages I mean I
watched the movie like an hour ago I
will say the lego movie is worth buying
on blu-ray I like the fact that this
movie addresses that different
generations of Legos they're different
Legos used to be you just had a bunch of
blocks and they're like you want to make
something we'll make something make
something of that and then make
something of yourselves now is like if
you want to make a Lego Star Destroyer
everything comes in the box specifically
to make a Lego Star Destroyer has to be
sounding old bagon rad a lego fort F I
would make a cube it's like here here's
a Lego cube I made it with four blocks
from here
right so the lego movie have you seen it
what did you think about it what was
your favorite Lego set growing up or now
shoot Legos are huge now if you have a
favorite now no one can fault you for it
whatever answer to any of the questions
might be comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you